[Musique]
c'est ça il faut que tu parle de quelque
chose aussi bons les examens soient pas
mais c'est pas grave si mais tu vas pas
mourir c'est encore 10 mois
mais qu'est ce que tu fous là ce matin
dit si tu t'inquiètes plus est
complètement cinglé mais bon ça va j'ai
envie cette séance que tu as envie de
faire là vraiment avant de mourir allez
sur la tombe d'albert schweitzer re lire
proust intégralement et oublier acheter
une corde pour le pendre
j'ai des goûts simples mois et ont passé
un buisson nul tu peux te dire un truc
je choisis un truc est l'hôte est obligé
de le faire je ne prends pas l'avion je
te préviens laïcité par la démocratie et
arbitres de négoce ou tu t'intéresses
fdt mais je suis inscrit à la cfdt
ça va sans doute vous paraître fou mais
je ne me suis pas mal non même pas mal
en fait c'est lui qui est malade
alors on fait quoi les corses en fait
quoi bah ça va la bringue la nouba la
fiesta
ainsi comment vas tu vous avez piccoli
ou quoi j'ai envie c'est de savoir ce
que tu as envie de faire et ce qu'on
peut faire ensemble
il a le droit de savoir que ça fasse
rire acura c'est pas ta vie arthur et sa
vie
n'importe quoi
vous étiez là
sur ce que des cépages aura du mal à
imaginer qu'on mérite
j'ai tout lâché pour être avec césar
c'est très beau t'as pas l'impression
qu'on a l'air content ouais mais de
combien l'habiller
[Musique]